worshipers at a mosque targeted as they
prayed minority shias were once again
the victim of this attack
it happened in the northern afghan city
of mazari sharif
reports say 10 people were killed and 40
were injured
a bag with explosives that was detonated
from a distance
isil in afghanistan say it was behind
the bombing
today the enemies of afghanistan bought
a big massacre to mazzare sharif
unfortunately as you can see in the pd2
area of seducon of masari sharif an
explosion occurred which was from
explosive material and approximately 25
people were killed and injured in this
incident
the taliban has been fighting groups
linked to isil since seizing power last
august in separate attacks several
people were killed when an explosion hit
a bus carrying airport workers in kunduz
province and four taliban members died
when an explosive device detonated near
their car these attacks come days after
two blasts outside schools in the shia
neighborhood of kabul
that attack killed at least six people
one of the major challenges for the
taliban government has been to provide
security
but minority communities continue to
live in fear assad beg al-jazeera